so the democratic party to me and
this is one of the things that it's
fascinating about your story
so you are one of the most prominent
progressives in the state of kentucky
uh you've identified the real issues
that people care about people will
listen to you because they they sense
that
you're a different voice and the
democrats not being
complete morons were like hey we should
try and recruit him
we should recruit this guy to run for
office and you get asked about it every
single cycle
which makes sense because you would be
one of the most successful prospects
that
they could possibly field and you went
so far as to attend a
one of those congressional candidate
training camps
and after you went through that you said
you know what i'm not sure i'm going to
run run that cycle i think it was 16
when they were talking to you
uh so tell us about why
you took a hard look uh and what your
experience was
well so i do a radio show every day and
i would argue
i am probably one of the only people in
the country who is a progressive and an
outspoken progressive that speaks to a
conservative audience every day
70 75 of my audience are trump voters
and that's because that's the sports
audience in kentucky and they know i'm a
progressive but they're okay with me
because they think
i think they think my heart is in the
right place so
in 2016 they called me up to consider
running against andy barr
in the congressional district that
represents lexington kentucky
and long story short they asked me to
come to this congressional boot camp
where they teach people how to run
and i went there and i was with the 50
to 60 candidates that were in the swing
districts that you had to win the sort
of purple districts
and it included a lot of names of people
that you would know
and they basically did a three-day camp
on how you went
and it was the most depressing thing i
have ever been a part of because my
theory my thought was okay they're going
to teach you how to
campaign how to talk about issues
they're going to talk about
you know what would what's a good policy
to have on this or that none of that was
a conversation
no one andrew even asked me what i
believed
on anything ever i mean they just
thought well you could win so you should
come and run
i could have believed any anything in
the world and they wouldn't have known
they didn't care they just thought i
could win and at the boot camp
all they taught you literally all they
taught you was how to raise money
the whole thing was about money a very
prominent congress person
stood up and said let me tell you what
doesn't matter meeting with voters
doesn't matter
your policies don't matter what matter
is what matters is how much money can
you raise and how do you utilize it
and when i heard her say that i knew i
wasn't gonna run because i was like i'm
not going to do this this is such a
terrible part of potentially being in
office and in congress especially in the
house
you have such little power that they
just see you as a number
to get to a majority and i came home and
i almost said you know what i'm done
with politics period it was that
depressing now i didn't do that
but it really showed me and i'm sure the
republicans have the same thing
it really showed me that at least at
that level it's not about issues it's
not about anything except
raising money and getting the vote to
get a majority
i'm the numbers guy madden they probably
told you this at the boot camp
but the average successful congressional
candidate raises
and spends 1.6 million dollars on their
campaign so you have to ask yourself
okay
who the heck can raise 1.6 million
dollars for a congressional campaign
but that's the reason they think the way
they do they're just like well let's say
you're a great human being you have
great vision
you know people really connect with you
but can you get 1.6 million dollars
and if not then none of your personal
qualities will care they become very uh
very mechanical do you believe that i
mean do you believe that because i don't
do you believe that do i believe that
that the average congressional candidate
that succeeds raises 1.6 billion
let's let's talk about what happened
here in kentucky during the senate
primary a guy named charles booker
who i endorsed and really liked a lot
nearly pulled off one of the most
shocking primary upsets ever
against amy mcgrath amy mcgrath raised
she's raised like 50 million dollars for
this senate campaign
at one point charles booker had like 30
dollars in the bank
and booker got the spark mostly via
social media
and the money came after and i'm sort of
of the belief
now you need a base money or at least a
base presence or a
social media something but the money for
charles he would have had
if he had gotten the nomination he'd had
all the money he needed against mitch
mcconnell anybody
heck yes yeah but he
basically just once he got the spark and
people knew who he was
he raised a lot of money and if he had
had one more week left in the election
he would have been the nominee and done
very well i think against mcconnell may
not have beaten him but he'd been close
i don't agree that it should be about
who can have the most money because i
think
steve bannon who i think is a contempt
contemptible person
but he said one thing i think is right
which is i actually think
argue art weirdly money almost matters
less now
because there are so many ways to get it
and when you get to big races you'll get
it anyway
because people will want you to win so i
i don't know that i totally agree with
that that like you gotta have that 1.6
million or why even do it
i agree with your disagreeing uh and
charles is a great example
candidates matter candidates matter a
great deal you know
it's it's it's one of the things that
prompted me to run was i thought you
know what like i i think that this
message needs to get out there and i
think people will connect with it
and i believe i'll get the resources i
need and i could have lived with myself
if i hadn't you know what i mean it's
not
like you could look at it say you can't
know that's one of the things about
these races too
and you hit the nail on the head with
charles like like if charles
puts himself out there then he has a
chance to get the resources he needs
you know it's like can you know that
someone ahead of time is going to get
the resources
sure in some cases if they're just
sitting on a giant pile of money
but the vast majority of candidates are
going to have to put themselves out
there and hope that they catch that
spark
and then when they do catch that spark
then magical things can happen
uh and those are the things that make
the dc establishment
uh look up and be like oh i did not see
that coming um what's happening in the
senate race too and i'd love to hear
what your your take is uh so amy mcgrath
i believe had
tens of millions of dollars for the
primary she was already spending money
on tv ads and the rest of it no one
expected charles to
um challenge her seriously and then it
became very serious
where he almost took the nomination
and she squeaked it out and then now
charles and everyone's behind her
because you got to try and beat mitch
um but it seems like she is not
as close as you'd hope uh last thing i
saw had her down like nine or ten points
so why is it that people in kentucky are
not excited about amy
and i you know i don't want to put words
in anyone's mouth but you know like
i don't know if you agree with the fact
that people aren't excited i i don't
know
i i don't want to be negative towards
amy because i think she is a good person
but
i she's going to lose by 20. i i i i i
really believe that
15 to 20. in mitch please i wrote about
i actually was thinking about that race
seriously i mean not just kind of
thinking about it i i went into it
i did polling i put my own personal
money into looking at it
and i detailed pretty you know
specifically how it is that candidates
end up not running and this is no
offense to amy mcgrath but
my race is an example so i was
considering running
and chuck schumer and the dscc decided
amy mcgrath's going to be our candidate
and what that was meaning was i could
not even
get people andrew to work for me there
are nine
polling uh democratic polling sources
and none of them would take me
because the dscc told them if you work
for him
you can't work for any of our candidates
i couldn't find
anyone to even help me the only people
that would help me were these sort of
rogue progressives
who were very nice but also didn't want
me to tell anybody they were working for
me because they were worried
that schumer and those people would get
mad at him schumer basically put
a if you help him and now when i say
schumer it was the dscc
specifically if you work for him
you can't do anything for us so there
was a major democratic party donor here
in kentucky and one of the biggest
national donors who like who thought i
was the best candidate
and basically went to schumer and said
look you got to give this guy a chance
and only because of that did he agree to
meet with me
and i talked specifically about what
happened in that meeting
it was a fine meeting he brought me up i
spent a couple hours with him
he agreed to finally like take his hand
off the button and let me
recruit people but he told me flat out
i don't think anybody can beat mitch
mcconnell we're for amy mcgrath because
we know she can raise money
and it will keep mitch distracted that's
he told me that flat out
and i said i think you're wrong someone
can beat him and he said well if you
want to try
go for it but their whole thing
was just to get someone who could raise
money and they knew that amy mcgrath was
a money-raising machine
they just gave up on kentucky before it
even started
and it was infuriating i ended up not
doing it but i have to tell you andrew i
almost did it just to
just to prove them wrong you know but
charles is a perfect example
charles and there's polling private
polling that suggests this
charles would have made this a much
closer race but chuck schumer didn't
care about it being a close race
he cared about the money being raised
and that's the problem
that is very tough to hear because there
are so many missed opportunities
really amy's background
um i mean she obviously has a very
impressive personal
and military background and she'd raised
a ton of money in an earlier race
um so what were those the reasons why
chuck looked up or the dscc looked up
and said okay um
we're going to get behind amy because
she'd
she like how much did she raise in her
previous race
well on paper she's a perfect candidate
military veteran
very smart engaging etc but
races are not run on paper she raised a
lot of money in 2018 in a midterm
partially because she put out one of the
best television commercials you'll ever
see which was her first commercial
which went viral and she raised a ton of
money but i think this is important
she lost and she lost when the polls
said
that she was going to win she way
underperformed expectations
but it was like nobody even cared they
just sort of moved past that
and said well you know still she's the
best candidate
i think what you get is when you have
people from washington dc
saying what they believe people in
kentucky will like
they're going to screw it up i mean what
do they know they're not in kentucky
if you had been here in 2018 and i say
this with no
offense to amy mcgrath who i think is
you know a good person
and and a military hero
but if you'd been here in 2018 you would
know that she could not beat mitch
mcconnell
and that putting her in the race in
kentucky was a terrible mistake you
would just
know that but i don't think anybody in
kentucky was ever even consulted
the question was just who did who did
chuck schumer want
and when chuck schumer wanted them they
win and i think there are other examples
around the country of that it is very
difficult in a primary
to beat the establishment pick so and
then the field gets weighted because
she raised so much money she raised like
eight million dollars her first two
weeks in the campaign
well andrew how am i supposed to compete
in a primary against somebody has eight
million dollars when
where and then when they tell big donors
don't give him money where am i supposed
to get any money
you know charles booker if it was not
for the black lives matter protest he
may have never even gotten
sort of noticed but he did because he
was such a great leader
during that time period but before that
she just had so much money it was
impossible and that was all done by the
national party
and this is a missed opportunity i'm not
gonna lie it would have been hard to
beat [ __ ] mcconnell would not have been
easy you would have had to run a
perfect race especially with trump on
the ballot if he wasn't on the ballot
it's different but
but it was possible thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode